rellena la tabla con números enteros
para escribir 22 de tres formas
diferentes aquí tenemos las decenas y
las unidades en las decenas vamos a
poner un 2 y en las unidades otro 2 dos
decenas 20 2 unidades ahora aquí vamos a
poner una decena y en las unidades vamos
a poner 12 unidades aquí en la tercera
opción vamos a poner 0 decenas y vamos a
poner 22 unidades vamos a ver nuestra
respuesta
estuvo muy bien vamos a hacer otro
ejercicio llegan los espacios para
completar la ecuación tenemos 94 mil 39
decenas de millas tres millares más un
espacio en blanco de centenas más tres
decenas tenemos nuestras tres decenas no
hay unidades hasta aquí vamos bien aquí
no tenemos centenas pero aquí en
millares nos dicen que son tres millares
y aquí tenemos cuatro millares cuatro
mil así que quitaron un millar de acá y
seguramente lo pusieron aquí en las
centenas así que vamos a poner diez
centenas que es un millar
y ahora si tenemos todos los elementos
necesarios vamos a comprobar la
respuesta muy bien estuvo bien vamos a
hacer otro ejercicio
ahora rellena la tabla con los números
enteros para escribir 210 de tres formas
diferentes centenas y decenas pues vamos
a poner dos centenas doscientos y una
decena que son diez otra forma es poner
un en centena y reacomodarlo dentro de
las decenas y nos queda once decenas la
última opción es poner cero en las
centenas y poner aquí veintiuno de seno
es comprobar respuesta muy bien creo que
con esto ya tenemos un mejor
entendimiento de lo que es la
reagrupación de los números enteros o
los números completos nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo